I've been able to avoid UFOs my entire
life with relative ease
and when our government takes a position
that makes it impossible to avoid that
by hiding its data
and making provocative statements
involving a thermonuclear
narrative I think it's wonderful that
you know the internet generation
feels so secure that we can have fun
with giant bug-eyed aliens and you know
Skinwalker Ranch and cattle mutilations
but when you actually are talking about
things probing your airspace or
areas in which
military presence is found
you're talking about something that
potentially could lead to a
conflagration
and so you know just the way I don't
expect people to be
um
you know singing popular songs in church
I don't really enjoy uh narratives about
UFOs in military airspace
so I think it's really important to
recognize that we have now been taken by
the New York Times by The Pentagon into
a very weird place where our scientists
don't seem to have any data
there are a tiny number of videos all of
which seem to me to be rather low
quality there's some anecdotal reports
and there's enough uh claimed behind the
scenes to Warrant a change indicating
that we were either lying before lying
now
um but whatever it is we've been putting
a tremendous amount of pressure on
people not to report things apparently
that they see because they don't want we
don't want career ending behavior in
Pilots
um this is one of the few issues that
I've never been able to fit
uh any curve through the points normally
the problem is you can fit too many
curves through a set of points then you
have to discriminate between which is a
likely narrative and which is a less
likely narrative I got nothing at the
moment I think what we're trying to fit
is a sheet that is too small on a
mattress that is too large and every
time we get one corner of the fitted
sheet onto the mattress another one pops
off I'm slightly worried that we've
misframed the problem the concern is
that many of us are hearing
a great deal more from other sources
that are not usually
I don't know unreliable people who I've
known who I've tracked their histories
people are reaching out
and the claim that I
don't know how to evaluate is that
there's a great deal more it's higher
resolution it's actually data rather
than sort of video anecdote
it appears that none of our top
scientists have access
to this at an official level they may
have secret access to it but I certainly
can tell you that I've poked around in
you know differential geometry general
relativity and Quantum field Theory
which would be three places I would want
to to consult if I thought that I was
being visited From Another Dimension
another part of the Galaxy or that there
was a major breakthrough that allowed
um alien civilizations to visit us
easily or even our own future selves
what have you and that's the data that
really I find fascinating it's not it's
not that look these videos you know to
the extent that they're actually just
straight up videos of something
they certainly seem weird I'm not I'm
not I'm not claiming that that it's
nothing but I don't think I've ever said
the words fraver or Tic Tac or Nimitz or
any of these things uh during the entire
discussion which I've been relatively
focused on not because
um
well because I don't think that's where
the story is I think that the story is
the Pentagon
authenticating the existence of a
program I'm I'm plugging in I'm seeing
all of these papers uh you know like 38
papers they seem to be from relatively
obscure academics for the most part
there seems to be a UFO community that
has security clearances there seem to be
top physicists who don't who know
nothing about this and all of this I
find
to be that it is the data the data is
the absolutely pathologically bizarre
disconnect between what appears to be
the strength of what has been released
and authenticated
with what is being claimed with the
extent to which things are being hidden
and the absence of any adults in the
defense complex or the intelligence
Community to shut down
uh what seems to be uh some sort of
um arguable fever dream on the part of
people who desperately want to meet
Aliens now I would say I desperately
want to meet Aliens but not so
desperately that I don't have other
things to do on this planet if there are
no aliens to be met and so my question
is where's my goddamn data it doesn't
really matter in some sense whether the
former paper of record uh turned I don't
know institution that isn't has
inscrutable motives we all know that the
New York Times has slid downhill at an
incredible level we're in a highly
politicized era people are desperate for
funding they're desperate for excitement
they can't find meaning in their lives
blah blah blah blah blah
we are still a thermonuclear nation and
we need bad narratives reigned in
because we're we're not even in a
bipolar situation we're in a multi-polar
situation
it is simply
uh if if Michael schurmer's best
explanation were true or if Mick West's
best explanation is true we've had a
massive collapse if we are at the level
in which we are talking about incentives
that one part of the Pentagon wants
money that another part of the Pentagon
has or people are squabbling and there's
no one to lower the boom and say cut it
out this is an extremely serious
situation what it's what it means to be
in the military you guys don't get it we
can't afford this I just I don't think
that any of this really resolves the
basic puzzle we can't actually have a
conversation we keep getting distracted
because we don't have the language that
says you have to you have to integrate
over the entire decision tree
you nobody can say that it's aliens and
what was represented to me just and I
checked before I came on the podcast
is that in essence all
what was represented is that all
plausible explanations
um appear to have been ruled out that's
a claim I'm not saying it's true I'm
saying that it's a claim there's also a
claim that there's a vast amount more
data and it is much higher quality that
it hasn't been down down sampled it
hasn't been degraded so as to preserve
um you know military Secrets I I don't
know how to evaluate it because I'm not
saying I'm not being lied to I'm not
saying that people are not themselves
confused
what I am saying is that
people are not representing the problem
correctly and if you set up the problem
in any one of various ways I can set it
up so that either absolutely this is a
funding dispute that got out of control
where people are trying to have some fun
and uh you know and it became this
International story or I can set it up
in a different way in which basically we
know it's aliens and we just can't say
that the final words when I asked Dan
Sheehan today was
are we at the point in your opinion or
in the opinion of people who came out of
the pentagon's atip program
that the only is the explanation for why
no one will say it's aliens
that all of the remaining
branches of the decision tree that we
can think of have career ending POS uh
implications
and I thought that that was a pretty
good way of grouping the set of things
like it you know it's Atlantis or orcas
developed opposable fins or were being
visited from other dimensions or these
are future humans going back in time
along closed time like curves or any one
of the things that would sort of get get
you a trip to the nuttery are those
what's left
and the answer that came back to me and
I and I hope Dan if if I think I I got
this straight so uh I will apologize if
I didn't understand it the Dan's answer
was yes that's what's left
now
does that mean that Dan knows Dan wasn't
part of atip he's a lawyer
does that mean that atip understands
this Maybe not maybe they're a bunch of
crazy enthusiasts I don't really
understand what a ufology I just found
out that ufology is a word that's how
backwards I am on this topic I am late
as late can be to this party it says had
zero interest to me
I think we are not representing the
weirdness of the story accurately if
we're already at quibono at some point
and I don't mean to be rude
you have to ask people with an above
adiq for help and if you're not willing
to do that then we are not
in in possession of we don't I I don't
understand something I I don't mean to
be rude about it
but we developed the world's best
Factory for producing smart people out
of ordinary human beings
and I know those people those are my
friends they're your friends
and we've got a large number of them and
they're completely in the dark
they are so far as I can tell unless
they've all been taken to
um you know method acting school and
each one of them can can put Dustin
Hoffman to shame nobody bothered to wake
the scientific community
the idea of saying we're going to have a
Manhattan Project
uh by getting Middle School teachers
together uh in in the desert
um and make PowerPoint presentations to
each other is not what you do you'd go
call the institute for advanced study
first and foremost they're like five
guys if I were just to go one place I'd
go pick up and Brian you and I have
fought about this before I'd pick up
edwit and Robert Digraph and Nima arkani
Hamed Juan malda Cena and Natty cyber
just be before breaking a sweat I call
up Jim Simons and ask for his help I
would make sure
that I was talking to people who are
have domain expertise with respect to
general relativity particle theory
differential geometry every time we got
into this conversation I hear about
Material Science and I say I really
don't care that much
you know at some level if it's just a
change in technology if somebody figured
out Hypersonic technology fine I get it
but this has become completely crazy the
idea that we avoid smart people at all
costs we make sure that there are no
smart people in our coveted narrative
there are no smart people in our physics
narratives they're no smart people and
our threats
this
yes I I understand I'm stepping into at
the following bear trap Eric you sound
elitist
no kidding look at the prosperity all
around you if you happen to live in an
advanced country you're welcome now get
the data to the smart people and stop
effing around you have to appreciate
every day I get up I look at the world
the world is so far shifted from what I
expect I write about it on Twitter I
used to do podcasts I will do them again
the reason people listen to me is that
I'm perpetually just scratching my head
and say what did somebody let off a
neutron stupid bomb all over the all
over the world now we're having the
craziest discussions about narratives
that make absolutely no sense
we
either have a significant threat or we
don't if you have a significant threat
you hired the people you train the
people you go talk to them in the 1950s
for example we appeared to have two
separate programs
that were dealing with anti-gravity and
uh involving the two separate
philanthropists one of them worked
through an aerospace company in a
military Air Force Base the other one
worked at the University system I
believe that the Higgs mechanism
bizarrely came out of all of this stuff
you know we have dabbled in this before
I looked through the list of names on
this 38 papers of atip I don't know that
atip is the only thing that's been
tasked with you know understanding this
we are not behaving
as an advanced technological Society
facing a genuine mystery with military
and safety implications
and
I will you know you will see people
writing things like wow Eric goes on a
great length he says the same thing
um
you know Paul erdish wasn't that
important of a mathematician he was very
good but he was like a combinatorist he
wasn't you're not talking about
Alexander grothendique you're not
talking about Michael Atia or Ed Whitton
I'm saying that we have people who would
I believe in general if we have real
data we'd go through this like the night
like a knife through butter now somebody
in the comments said something but has
Eric never heard of the jasons well
one how badly degraded are the adjacents
uh if you know that this is supposed to
be our super Elite um
advising group I believe we tried to
shut them down because we can't figure
out why we still train smart people uh
we're behaving like
lunatics who built the society that was
able to build the Blackbird to build the
bombs to do all of the amazing things
that we do our chip factories
nobody in the private sector would put
up with this kind of avoidance
of scrutiny and one of the reasons that
it was is least likely to be aliens is
least likely to be anything really
exciting
is is that no one's scared enough to
make a trip to Cambridge Massachusetts
Berkeley California Princeton New Jersey
Hyde Park
Illinois I don't know
I I just don't know how to think about
people who avoid smart people and
continually have discussions about
nothing I mean look at these papers this
is not what we're supposed to be doing I
I deal with colleagues who believe that
peer review is is an intrinsic part of
science which is clearly not true
the brainwashing of our scientific
institutions the the fact that we don't
know the history of the golden age of
general relativity that we don't
understand the way in which anti-gravity
intersected the way that we don't
understand that we distributed programs
in the interstitial regions between
non-profits like universities government
agencies like units of the military and
private corporations like our Aerospace
corporations we used to know how things
got done
and then we passed the Mansfield
amendment in the late 1960s early 1970s
to put the kibosh on Military funding of
Civilian research
and we went completely insane I mean I
understand their motivation for not
wanting the military to be directing
civilian research during the Vietnam war
but when you knock out a load-bearing
wall you are responsible for putting
some support in its place before the
destruction is complete you should
either release the data or you should
get the smart people uh in one place as
we have done in the past to say look we
got a problem uh we've got a Blue on
Blue situation our UFO enthusiasts have
stumbled on our top secret drone program
or on the knowledge that we've been
leapfrogged by our adversaries or
something like this but you don't just
like not worry about it